on the topic of Consciousness you know
there's so many components
to even just removing Consciousness from
the data set
emotion the display of Consciousness the
display of emotion feels like deeply
integrated with the experience of
consciousness
so the hard problem seems to be very
well integrated with the actual surface
level illusion of Consciousness so
displaying emotion I mean do you think
there's a case to be made that we humans
when we're babies are just like gbt that
we're training on human data on how to
display emotion versus feel emotion how
to show others communicate others
that I'm suffering that I'm excited that
I'm worried
that I'm lonely and I missed you and I'm
excited to see you all of that is
communicated there's a communication
skill versus the actual feeling that I
experience so
we need that training data as humans too
that we may not be born with that how to
communicate the internal State and
that's in some sense if we remove that
from GPT Force data set it might still
be conscious but not be able to
communicate it
so I think you're going to have some
difficulty removing all mention of
emotions from gpt's data set I
would be relatively surprised to find
that it has developed exact analogs of
human emotions in there I think that
humans have will like have like
emotions even if you don't tell them
about those emotions when they're kids
it's not quite exactly what
various blanks blank slatists try to do
with the new Soviet man and all that but
you know if you try to raise people
perfectly altruistic they still come out
selfish
you try to raise people's sexless they
still develop sexual attraction
um you know we have some notion in
humans not in AIS of like where the
brain structures are that implement this
stuff and it is really remarkable thing
I say in passing that despite having
complete read access to every floating
Point number in
um the GPT series we still know vastly
more about the the architecture of human
thinking then we know about what goes on
inside GPT despite having like vastly
better ability to read GPT
do you think it's possible do you think
that's just a matter of time do you
think it's possible to investigate and
study the way neuroscientists study the
brain
which is look into the darkness The
Mystery of the human brain by just
desperately trying to figure out
something and to form models and then
over a long period of time actually
start to figure out what regions of the
brain do certain things with different
kinds of neurons when they fire what
that means how plastic the brain is all
that kind of stuff you slowly start to
figure out different properties of the
system do you think we can do the same
thing with language models uh sure I
think that if you know like half of
today's physicists stop wasting their
lives on string theory or whatever
and go off and study what goes on inside
Transformer networks
um then in
you know like 30 40 years uh we'd
probably have a pretty good idea